the following video is a conversation
with kevin o'leary he's the star of abc
shark tank and he also has a number of
various asset management businesses
across different financial markets
in this conversation kevin and i talk
about everything from nuclear-powered
bitcoin miners to regulation disclosures
law stable coins regulators and much
much more i really enjoyed this
conversation with kevin as i always do
and i hope that you guys enjoy these as
well don't forget that this episode is
brought to you by ftx us you can go
click on the link in the description and
learn about how their cheap fees
sometimes as much as 85 cheaper than any
of their competitors will help you get
started with bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies all right let's get in
this episode with kevin i hope that you
guys really enjoy this conversation
mr o'leary how are you my friend great
to be here thank you so much of course
how are you
well i'm crispy around the edges
[Laughter]
let's jump right into it uh bitcoin
mining the public miners are down
significantly uh you were telling a lot
of people that you were getting out of
mining stocks a few months ago what's
your general read right now on miners
and kind of the price drawdown that
they've experienced alongside the
drawdown in bitcoin price well you
remember uh this this
problem started about a day after the
original memo from the sec
about five months ago talking about
carbon credits being audited
and so basically what's happened since
is
and this is a little complicated but
the data is is irrefutable now
when you set up a mining operation
as we had multiple public miners last
year
uh they were being used as a proxy
by institutions to buy bitcoin because
the price of the mining shares whether
it was a hot aid or a riot or marathon
um
and not and many others uh really wasn't
was a great proxy for bitcoin volatility
you bought those shares bitcoin goes up
the shares went up bitcoin goes down the
shares go down it was almost a perfect
correlation regardless of how many
megawatts each of these companies had
mining nobody cared about the source of
power at that time
but then along came that memo when
basically what it said is look if you're
a public company you got to get your
auditors to sign your public statements
and we're going to add a little
attribute if we have our way we're going
to actually if you're using carbon
credits or offsets
we're going to have you sign that too
and basically what the sec was saying is
they were calling bs on carbon credits
so many companies said look yeah i'm
using coal or flared gas to to mine
bitcoin but i bought an acre of the
amazon it's got a thousand trees so it's
an offset
well the sec said
get me an auditor to sign that so if you
call any of the big five audit firms
they're not going to sign that because
there's no ledger to carbon credits
it was that day and i won't forget it
when i started getting calls from the
larger sovereign and institutional
accounts that were using the index
to strategize holding bitcoin by holding
the public miners
and wow were they dumping stock
so
i mean
they read the writing on the wall
a lot of these companies are going to
face bankruptcy because they leverage
their bitcoin mining
borrowed money to
you know build more facilities and
they're offside 50 60 plus leverage
but the bigger problem pomp is this
let's say you want to raise new capital
because i'm in the mining business and i
want to raise let's say you're going to
do a 300 megawatt facility in a friendly
state like north dakota or montana or
south carolina where you can get power
you can get a plug in for less than four
cents a kilowatt hour which is what you
need to be globally competitive
you have to find a power source behind
the meter in other words where you can
prove to someone that you are compliant
from a carbon perspective and that
really points to nuclear power and hydro
power so all of a sudden places like
northern norway where we have a facility
being built in a company called bizzero
we're behind the meter every electron
comes from a giant hydro dam no need for
a carbon audit and we're able to raise
money because the institutions that
provide the funding whether it be debt
or equity understand there's no risk
take any other public minor ask them
where their power comes from they say
it's blended
they don't know basically and that's the
problem the existing miners have in a
way they're kind of screwed but i think
a new generation of miners emerging i'm
not the only guy doing this there's
other funds out there that are basically
finding hydro and nuclear power and
regenerating this industry from scratch
at a carbon zero footprint it's not just
bitcoin mining it's ethereum it's any
data center
this is going to be the issue going
forward so the older miners their stocks
are down 70 to 90
not coming back
sorry
kevin is it your belief that many
bitcoin miners should go and start using
nuclear power to mine bitcoin
yes absolutely and hydropower there's no
question about it what if there's excess
power there's no better way to store the
value than mining there's no better way
and so the mining industry which has
taken such a bad bad bad pr
extremely bad pr in the last six months
it couldn't be worse getting accused of
every disease known to man
they're actually doing something very
important they're advancing technology
and mining technology and semiconductor
technology and heat technology every
generation every 36 months later there's
a new technology that's more efficient
in terms of mining which is a good thing
for everybody else and also they're
taking excess power let's go back to
norway in the 50s they built so much
hydroelectricity that over half of it's
never used it goes over the dam and it's
never used now with bitcoin mining these
miners can go into those communities and
create jobs data centers excess heat is
doing hydroponic growth there because
they're in basically an arctic climate
and storing value by creating bitcoin
paying taxes in norway they don't get
thrown out of the country they're
embraced by the government there because
they see the imputed value look at what
happened in new york all of that power
going over niagara falls is being wasted
because no bitcoin miners can set up
there the government's gone berserk and
chased all the capital out of there in
fact that norway project started in
upstate new york and after the
government went wonky on policy in that
state moved all of the mining facility
to norway where they're accepted so
there's a lot of differences between
policy in different states you've got to
go find the ones that are willing to
embrace the concept
of mining for the reasons that it has
merit which is basically to store value
in unused power
one of the most important um kevin one
of the most important topics right now
in finance is inflation we've seen the
president united states president biden
come out and order via twitter uh gas
stations to lower their prices we've
seen them blame everybody from trump to
covid to putin the whole nine yards what
is going on and are they simply as jeff
bezos suggested trying to do
misdirection on inflation or do they not
actually understand the basic market
dynamics of what's driving the inflation
that we're facing right now
unfortunately uh for biden in the
administration there were some policy
mistakes made early in the mandate over
two years ago particularly around energy
there's two pressure points that are
causing all of this political activity
one is inflation on energy you know five
to seven dollar gasoline per gallon is
just a killer when it comes to midterm
elections there's no getting around that
problem because people see that every
time they fill up their truck or car
and then of course
protein the food supply chain in the u.s
from chicken on down is up between 30
and 48 percent so food and energy are
very political in nature because you're
forcing families to spend so much more
of what they make on things that they
never have to worry about now they do
heating their homes and just feeding
their families and so
it's very difficult to reverse the
mistakes made in energy let's start
there canceling the xl pipeline
cancelling leaseholds on federal land
shutting down offshore development
cancelling the activity that was going
on
in alaska which was very prolific in
terms of providing gas and oil really
making it hard to figure out carbon
costs if you're if you're using um you
know any kind of fracking service and so
all of a sudden
of course
we're no longer energy independent we're
in a perverse situation that even before
the ukraine war we had russian tankers
coming into the boston harbor so that's
policy mistakes and you know takes time
to fix that
when biden goes over to saudi arabia to
get more oil from them it won't matter
to energy prices in the us because we
don't have enough refinery capacity we
just canceled another refinery we need
three more again bad policy now where
this is going to manifest itself in a
very ugly way
is in any midterm election the incumbent
loses seats in the house
i fear for biden's administration a
complete
slaughter fest in the midterm election
everything's going to turn it's going to
be brutal and i i think
what what do you do what can you do if
you want balance you're not going to get
it here there's going to be a lot of
seats lost in the democratic party and
in a way they did that to themselves on
bad policy
of course they're scrambling and
anything can happen between now and
fourth quarter
but
i'm not optimistic for him and you know
he he was given a mandate to solve for
the pandemic he did a reasonably good
job there but this energy policy and
what happened in inflation caught him
off guard and i'm not sure what can be
done to fix it because it's not getting
better anytime soon
yeah it's pretty crazy
speaking of politics we can talk about
regulation we've seen gbtc and the
grayscale team they're trying to convert
into an etf uh their most recent
application was denied uh and so within
hours they went ahead and they began the
process to sue the sec their argument is
the sec has already approved uh futures
based etfs both long and short there's
other spot bitcoin etfs around the world
we don't have one here in the united
states i don't know how much you can
comment or not but what's your general
take on bitcoin spot etf in the united
states and maybe grayscale's chances to
be the first to get that conversion
yeah um
here's how i look at it from the
perspective of working in financial
services and working within the system
on a regulated basis and i have for
years
suing the sec
is a really bad idea
it virtually never works they have
unlimited resources it's a bravado thing
to do and i'm sure others in the
industry are applauding this
but the outcome is never good because
they don't like getting sued
and they have
tremendous powers
uh to avoid being embarrassed and trying
to embarrass the regulator into
submission
well pomp that just doesn't work
and so um this is not the path of least
resistance
and i i do not want to you know comment
on
on what they're attempting to do other
than saying from my point of view it's a
personal opinion
it borderlines it you know it borders on
insanity it's it's not a good play book
and i've i think if i were on that board
um
i would be i would be pretty noisy in in
in the boardroom about this now having
said all that i'm more optimistic on
other strategies in terms of getting
some policy in crypto
and i you know we we should talk about
the next six months because
you've got
lots of evidence now of bipartisan
interest in getting some policy in place
not in a combat way by suing regulators
but in a way in cooperation
on a bipartisan basis and let's make it
real easy okay we're not going to get
everything regulated overnight we may
not get an etf in the u.s for two or
three more years but that's not the only
thing that matters
what i'd like to see and a lot of others
too
would take
one asset
one asset a really
bipartisan asset
in the form of stable coin now not all
stable coins were created equal we know
the meltdown and luna that story is well
known algorithmic based you know stable
coins may not be the best idea be very
hard to launch another one but assets
like usdc
that are backed by the us dollar have
not broken a buck recently
and
if that was made
and was allowed to be regulated it could
become the default payment service for
the world backed by the us dollar
because everybody would use it
because so many commodities including
oil are actually paid in u.s dollars
imagine if you could use usdc to
transfer between jurisdictions and
geographies it's far more efficient
better ledger more transparent lower
cost way faster
what senator
doesn't like that idea making the u.s
dollar king dollar
keeping it at the supreme default
currency i don't care what party you're
in that's a good idea
the policy being proposed by the toomey
and hagarty bills and even contemplated
in the limits bill which has much more
than just stable coin let's just take
the stable coin
if toomey's going to retire in january
he's he would endorse this if you could
get it passed
in the last by the last and the end of
this year it would be a fantastic thing
and everybody in the crypto industry
including all the institutions that
don't own it yet would see the very
first marker
of policy on a very basic asset
stable coins and contemplated in the
policies very simple
full audit every 30 days what's wrong
with that makes sense to me and no
assets held supporting the token or coin
with a duration longer than 12 months
what's wrong with that that looks like a
money market by fidelity or by schwab
i've been talking about this now for
three months and i'm really working hard
going to washington trying to do
whatever i can as a private citizen to
push that agenda just one thing let's
get one thing done and i will also note
since you and i last talked that
fidelity and blackrock each put in 200
million dollars that's a lot of money
into a series f
as circle
now that if that isn't accommodating and
supporting the notion of a regulated
stable coin i don't know what is what
what isn't i mean that that is as good
as it gets those are the most
conservative financial institutions in
the world supporting the idea of a
stable coin backed by the u.s dollar
talk to me about disclosures you
mentioned obviously luna there's a lot
of people who had questions there we've
seen many other companies
that have struggled over the last couple
of months and it feels like alongside
this idea of more regulation is more
requirements on uh the disclosure front
what are you seeing there what do you
think is the likely path that we'll get
there's no question there's gonna
there's gonna have to be more disclosure
there's gonna have to be more
transparency but the truth is and
this is something the entire industry
has to really get their head around
if we can get some policy even though it
will require additional compliance costs
more disclosure more transparency
it opens the floodgates of institutional
capital have been waiting to come into
the crypto market
just in a payment system alone
let's say four or five different stable
coins got licensed
it would be a phenomenal outcome because
you would for the first time be able to
get a one or two or three percent
indexed allocation
from sovereign funds running 500 to 900
billion dollars the kind of guys that i
service in the indexing business i'm not
the only person doing it there's lots of
others but we talk to these funds all
the time and they say the same thing
over and over again
give me some policy show me i'm not
offside with the sec and i'll give you a
one percent allocation sometimes a three
percent allocation that goes for bitcoin
that goes for ethereum solana polygon
stable coins
just give me a regulated position that's
all they want so for all of the angst
and all the headaches and everybody
worrying and gnashing their teeth and
rubbing their hands together about
disclosure who cares let's get this
policy done and if you want if you want
to see bitcoin a hundred thousand
dollars that's how you're going to do it
you're going to get the sovereign wealth
funds to allocate to it i'm a believer
in that that's why i stay long in these
troubled and difficult times but i'm 100
compliant everything i touch is
regulated whether i own an exchange in a
country like canada or trying to buy a
license in the uae i'm working with the
regulator i don't want to be a crypto
cowboy
it just shows you what happens when
you're crypto cowboy you get wiped out
you and i both have on suits and ties
right now it's like the old days where
you used to tell me all the time you say
hey i forbid you but now here we are
together sitting in the regulated crypto
market what are you most worried about
over the next let's call it six to 12
months what's the thing that you're like
man people really got to pay attention
to this and i don't think enough people
are paying attention to whether it's a
risk or a potential surprise on the
horizon
so
people ask me every hour of the day
are we at the bottom is the time to buy
and we're not and the reason i say that
is
let's just talk crypto markets all
crypto markets i don't care what asset
clash you're in within crypto markets
what coin what token what asset what
project
i don't care it doesn't matter we're not
at the bottom yet
what defines
a good bottom
is a panic event now we've had some good
bankruptcies but they're all small you
know this yesterday's announcement
voyager it's irrelevant it's so small
and so
decentralized in the sense that the the
shareholders are all over the place and
it's not really um
going to hurt anything and but
so it doesn't bring the panic bottom
that you need
what defines great bottoms is panic in
the streets massive capitulation massive
selling massive volatility and then you
flush it out that big toilet in the sky
has to flush
it's coming soon i feel it coming
somebody's offside somebody's over
levered these small guys going to zero
just never knew how to manage risk
because they never experienced anything
like this now the good news for them is
they've learned you know learn
grasshopper learn don't leverage
yourself up like that with an asset that
you can't ever peg the bottom on so they
got wiped out so what it's a great
learning experience for them they'll be
much better managers going forward and
the shareholders chalk it up to
entertainment no different than going to
las vegas you took that kind of chance
with leverage you got wiped out
learn that's the whole point but the big
event hasn't happened yet it's coming to
a theater near you shortly i don't know
who it's going to be
somebody's gnashing their teeth right
now somebody's way over leveraged
somebody's trying to borrow cash and
tomorrow morning you might find out who
it is i'm looking forward to that one
that's when you go back into the market
when it's absolute panic in the streets
and it will happen
when you think that we're at the bottom
which you claim that we are not yet
we'll see uh do you just take a slug of
cash and you're all in on one shot or do
you try to dollar cost average your way
in like what's your strategy whether
it's in crypto or just other markets in
general how do you normally think about
re-entering a market
yeah i've never been able to time the
bottom it's impossible so i've already
started to layer in uh primarily in
equities now because you know we're
still not at the bottom there either
because ps are still a little expensive
i anticipate if we could get down to
fifteen fifty and a half pe on the s p
then you can cherry pick the top hundred
you know highest quality balance sheets
in the s p 500 and that'd probably be a
good place to put some money to work and
you'd be layering in nobody knows about
the recession it's pretty hard to have a
recession to full unemployment you know
for employment i mean we don't have uh
you know any
this is not your typical recession i can
tell you that i haven't even seen any
results yet of private companies i've
invested in slowing down at all yet we
can't even hire anybody so we're in a
different kind of time right now and
we'll have to see where that goes but in
crypto you get a lot more volatility and
you know obviously the granddaddy asset
is bitcoin is holding its own at 20 000
but if you saw that spike down in a
panic sell-off that somebody had to off
their coin because they're you know
being margin called out and that thing
dropped to 15 000 or something that
would be a good place to start putting
money to working again and i'm not
saying it will or won't happen it's just
we're not at the bottom yet of that i'm
sure and so you gotta you gotta you know
hold your nose and wait and see what
happens and in the meantime if you have
a position as i do you just ride it out
i don't use any leverage in crypto
zero leverage so it can go to zero and
it doesn't wipe me out
crypto is not leverageable yet it needs
to have policy and it has needs to be
regulated and then the volatility will
go down then you can put on some
leverage to goose returns the guys that
put on the leverage are
wiped out and every day you hear another
story
wiped out to zero you got pants on
no no pants on
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right my friend listen i appreciate
you as always coming on where can we
send people to find out more about what
you're doing in bitcoin and crypto well
kevin o'leary tv on every platform you
know linkedin right through to twitter
my fastest-growing platform uniquely
which is so interesting because now a
lot of kryptonians are there it's
tick-tock who knew are you on tick-tock
yeah you bet i got hundreds of thousands
i just started i'm up to 600 and
something thousand so it's really uh
taking off and it's our fastest growing
platform and that content is unique you
have to produce it as you know make me a
promise hold on make me a promise you
don't go on tick tock have your team
post it cause i can't lose you i don't
need you addicted to tick-tock
i'm on tick-tock every day you know what
i what i try and do is have some fun
with all of this you know it's it's you
gotta you have to realize that
no one knows with certainty particularly
in crypto what's going to happen next
but
we're starting to see and this is really
good in this sense the reason i think we
should all be optimistic probably a
great way to leave this is that every
time you see
a company go to xero that's a broken
business model that's been wiped off
forever no one's going to do the same
thing again everybody's going to learn
from that mistake so
you know i don't want to name the the
zeros but you know who they are they're
happening every day now
when they go to xero it's a good thing
because that business model that amount
of leverage that idea does not return
anytime soon and so the market gets
better and so the remaining assets get
stronger and that's you know my premise
you can see all the work that sam
bankman freida's doing looking at all
these opportunities taking new positions
all over the place he's probably buying
at the bottom in some of these
situations so i think it's a pretty
smart move on his on his side but
there's a guy that understands leverage
i mean he's been in in the trading
business forever and so he understands
risk mitigation some of these other guys
forgot about that and
they're learning a very important lesson
as always at kevin o'leary tv on all
platforms and uh you know every once in
a while on abc shark tank as well i
appreciate it very much and we'll talk
soon
take care bye-bye all right later buddy